you
today is a day that will change the
course of the war
that his play this city may soon be
coming to an end scientists may have
finally found the one that will lead us
to the cure everything they've told you
is a lie sums up to escape that's so in
the building it'll kill us all put it
down nah
for 12 years I was held captive by the
humans the world I once knew has changed
vampires and lycans are now the hunted
if we are to survive as a species we
must resist the humans this is a new war
something else escaped let's go she's
the only hybrid child who was ever
existed the humans have like him to hunt
her down at any expense
any idea what you're up against
created something more than twice the
size of any like and I've ever seen
whatever it is they want from her that's
worth dying for
she is the key to winning this war
we stand and we fight
you kind will never be as powerful as us
no matter how hard you fight you won't
win you don't know me very well
this day was bound to come
you